in this video we will be rating
minecraft servers with 10
000 people i have a discord with over a
quarter of a million people in it and
when we throw an address in there
they're going to flood a server
first we want to see if we can crash a
low tier server which is what we're on
we're going to see if we can crash this
before we go to real servers carl
throw the ip in the chat okay
are you prepared for war yeah
i don't know why you are carl this isn't
war this is a minecraft server i just
love
war people are already joining as you
can see i'd say we have
what a dozen people oh i'm gonna trap
them in tnt
all right so far we have 65 players make
a big crater for them all right we're up
to 150
players come on that ain't no 10 000 the
server has frozen
it's like the pause challenge 269
players nice
we only got 2.6 of the way to 10 000.
and it already crashed it's not gonna
last i think we've gotten the point
across
it took 269 players to crash the low
tier server
and timed out okay guys rejoin the
second server now i'm in the mid tier
server you know it's mid-tier because
there's sheep
all right let's get them john's in here
i'm opening the server
all right go carl now let's test the
mid-tier server all right well we built
the crater for them
carl you told us that's where they would
spawn we tried to burn out all these
trees and now it just looks like an
apocalypse so far we have 106 people and
the server's holding up pretty well or
any of you lagging no i'm doing pretty
good right now i like the idea that
they're like
finally i got in the server they were
just like
lighting them on fire pushing them in
holes yeah i love how people are like
yeah i get to be in a mr beast challenge
for like no anarchy
i'm giving this guy the dilemma
[Music]
no you won't go back in oh you're
getting trapped now buddy
oh he killed himself oh look at the
memory it's going up we're using so much
memory
hey somebody open up the floodgates you
want me to put the surfer back in
yeah put it back in here wait jimmy
let's do the old-fashioned way with this
guy
oh my god it's like he fell into an ant
colony oh we have 350 people
yeah so we have more people than last
time and it still hasn't crashed yet oh
it's getting laggy it's getting laggy
all right so we're up to 500 players and
i mean you can tell you can tell like
it's kind of unplayable already
look at this it's like they're all
little ants just squirming around it's
getting really laggy for me
this might be it oh it's happening 6
24 we're climbing oh no the the rubber
banding is so absurd i can't even place
blocks anymore
poor people who are joining this
nightmare hey 700. do i hit 800. there's
no
chance this makes it to 800. i just lit
some tnt around a bunch of people
it's not even blowing up for me anymore
800. hey do i hear 900.
how is the server still open if this is
a mid-tier server i can't wait till we
start actually going to real servers
we're going to break minecraft we
cracked 900 boys are we gonna get to a
thousand
is it just me or does flying around just
feel different
oh come on let's go 10 more
a thousand and there you go a mid-tier
server can handle 1000 players
i don't know if handel's the best word
beautiful a thousand
okay it's officially completely frozen
for me and rip the
server shut down it could only handle
1100 people
now we are in the high tier server this
one we're gonna have a little fun with
they're gonna spawn in this obsidian box
let's see if they can break out this box
before they crash the server oh
hey post the link ip coming in
oh it's been a total of five seconds and
199 people have joined
oh the entity cramming is hard oh my god
chris let's see what happens if i open
this door right here i'm lagging bro
oh my gosh is it already gonna break why
is the high tier server worse than the
low tier immediately it's because we're
cramming entities
i open the gates let's see what happens
nothing
here let me walk in there oh dude this
is amazing this is so
trippy oh my gosh this is like being in
a techno concert i want them to come
down this pathway
oh yeah oh there they go oh yeah
oh man let's see if it reduces the lag
if we free them be free my children
i can't even tell what's happening
anymore that's what's happening oh there
they go
we're up to 750 players
it's just vomiting people everywhere all
right well up
you want to know something boys what's
that does it just end at the high tier
server
i bought a mega tier server the biggest
of the biggest servers
is simp craft.com
no joke we got that domain zipcraft.com
pro go spamsemcraft.com on our discord
let everybody know where the sims
collected
oh wait they're breaking my paintings no
all right look at all the sims
wait how are so many people flying i
think they're just floating due to lag
it's like playing pac-man dying and then
taking a piece of paper
writing one on it and duct taping it in
front of your high score that's what
we're doing right now
i it's good enough for me they don't say
i'm great at analogies for nothing who'd
be saying that
my mom dang yo mama a liar
i love how the server where we asked for
the sims to join
it's the one that hit a thousand players
the fastest what you're saying is we
have a lot of symptoms for fans we do
have a lot of senpai's fans
i know why it crashed it's because it's
nicholas cage skin it's only got eleven
hundred does
putting people that close together
really make that big of a difference yes
look it's already at
10 gigabytes used you know what's funny
about making fun of symphs
the only way people can get offended is
if they admit they're a simp
and then if they met their ascent their
opinions and valid
exactly bro it's the joker in a mr beast
shirt
1500 i'm tp and i'm all right to me
[Music]
oh everybody disappeared everybody's
gone
oh they all back boys this is fun and
all
but i think it's time we actually start
crashing real servers that we don't own
okay and just you know yesterday we got
permission to crash these servers we
talked to server owners beforehand i
know this is their livelihood and
obviously we didn't want to screw anyone
so don't worry about that
before we raid this server called
dungeons of the spire we want to test it
out and see you know is it worthy of all
the traffic
uh if we like the server we'll rate it
uh this is dope oh
whoa whoa guys come out get him get him
get him go go
go yo guys i watch anime where they do
this stuff all the time i got us
i don't like these naked men running at
us though i'm gonna be honest i've got a
healing staff do you guys need healing
no we're good right now well i healed us
all right let's do it oh i thought these
things said google i was like
why is cuckoo a slime in this dungeon oh
i died i tried to protect you chris i'm
trying to protect you i'm gonna switch
to healing staff go
go go go go go go okay okay i'm damaging
oh wait there's guys up here they're
coming for us i'm gonna need your help
i'm a mage i don't do as much damage as
you
oh boss fight watch out for the slimes
no dude the boss is getting me you got
to help
oh i can't see anything he'll steal his
heels
i'm near you i don't have enough mana to
heal dude you didn't heal me
i'm trying i'm about to die carl watch
mind you watch out from behind you
you tricked me
i've almost got him
got it got it i'm a dungeon master
and that is how the dungeons on this
server work now let's rate it i shouted
out this public server
let's see if we can make it crash look
at all our fans pouring in
it just keeps teleporting me back to the
other side because it's like no you
don't get to see the content
all right well it's not working for me
literally nothing's working for me
anymore
500 people in the last minute i can't
move look see this is my mouse
it doesn't work my whole game crashed
and there you have it if you try to send
10 000 people into a server it just
crashes
now we know now you might be wondering
why am i wearing purple why is chandler
here and why is carl wearing something
different
well it's been a week since we raided
the servers when we
leaked all those servers i owned earlier
to see if they'd crash some people for
whatever reason stuck around for the
entire week and are still
on it as you see right here 22 people
are currently on this server there's
literally no incentive for them to stay
on it chandler
are you curious what they were up to
yeah i mean i don't know all right i am
stuck in a tree
where am i i'm in so much cobblestone
right now what happened
what wait oh my gosh oh whoa what did
they do
what we just left the server open and
then just this mountain
happened oh oh i see it oh my gosh
there isn't world edit on this by the
way they did all this
in survival mode too what on earth let's
see if we can find one of the people on
the server and talk to them on discord
like why did they do this i need to know
wait this person's name is mrs carl
jacobs somebody put a tree in the sky
jimmy come over here you gotta want to
see this
what up everybody oh hello hello why
have you guys just been chilling on the
server just cuz
it's an epic server we made these
servers just to test rate them we didn't
actually expect people to play on them
and the community is pretty epic too oh
yeah
it is freaking epic it's actually really
cool i really do like the server
all right fine we'll leave the server up
you guys drive a hard bargain
carl did you realize that you had a wife
on the minecraft server i just found it
out
i'm excited i thought i was going to be
lonely forever uh your your wife sang i
love you carl and chat
i love you wife okay wow don't remember
her name that's sad
not that i don't remember it i've never
heard it to be fair
all right well i hope you guys all
enjoyed the server we're gonna go read
another one see you guys around
all right bye guys and now we're gonna
raid one final server look at all the
beautiful artwork
look at saturn i hope they can withstand
the onslaught bring them on in
they're all coming in our fans are here
be free my children
we believe in you are we crashing it are
you really a mr b
subscriber if you don't help us rate
minecraft servers it's a character made
out of wood
they're all frozen i think we crashed
the server and so far only 106 people
have joined
look how many people are piling in
there's a whole nother group
like down below look dude it's a
standstill
no one is moving the server is oh oh
we had a little bit of movement how's
the server not done all right i think
they get the point we crashed the server
shout out to voidrealms thank you for
letting us crash your server if you're
not already hit that subscribe button if
we hit 10 million subscribers before the
end of the year me chandler chris carl
will all get tattoos see you later